افادت مصادر ومحليه للجزيره بان الجيش
التركي المتمركز في مناطق المعارضه شمال
غربي سوريا استهدفت مركزات ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا ديمقراطيه في قريه صيدا بمحيطي عين
عيسى شماليه الرقه وقريه تل اللبن بمحيطه
التمر شمال الحسكه لما افادت مصادر
للجزيره في المعارضه السوريه المسلحه بان
المدفعيه الجيش التركي المتميزه بمحيطي
اعزاز على الحدود مع تركيا استهدفت
تحصينات ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
في محيطه الرفعه بريف حلب
اكد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ضروري
تطهير الحدود مع سوريا بعمق 30 كيلو مترا
من من سماهم الارهابيين تماشيا مع اتفاقي
سوتشي لعام 2019 وفي اتصال بالرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اشار اردوغان الى استمرار
ما وصفها بالانشطه الانفصاليه لحزب العمال
الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب وحزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي في شمال سوريا
واستمرار الهجمات الارهابيه التي تهدد
تركيا بحسب بيان الرئاسه التركيه اما
الكرملين فقال ان بوتن واردوغان بحث حلا
النزاعي على اساس اتفاق سوتشي